uh how long have you been rapping
um I've been I want to say I took raps
serious
like when I was 16 I've been rapping way
before that I fell in love with it like
when I was nine of course or what made
you fall in love with it
um G Unit you know Gina was like a big
influence to me um my dad used to sell
like old school music so when I was a
kid four three five years old he would
push me around while he sold this music
so he would tell like uh like burnt CDs
type [ __ ] he was so at the time it was
tapes oh cassette then CDs came a little
while that's what I used to do that's
how I got my name I used to be at the
swap meet with [ __ ] CDs mixtapes all
the Junior Radio [ __ ] so I used to be
[ __ ] getting it in
so definitely pirating a lot of people's
music back in the day before I was uh
anybody what year was that you said 2000
uh oh 40506 okay CD that's like when the
CDs come in I don't even remember I just
remember the transition the 90s the 90s
right yeah it was the 90s it was like
nah it might not have been the 90s it
was early 90s
yeah when I was a kid I had doggy style
on CD no I had it on tape but then I got
it on CD and like
yeah CDs was like mid 90s because I had
I bought uh like what what would you say
mid I bought a quemini from Walmart so
it's probably like 97 where it was like
kind of like the norm
it was like 96 97 98 it was kind of like
because I remember buying CDs
I don't remember many tapes but boys
demand um
yeah but look when CDs came out people
still kind of use cassette tapes yeah
same thing with now people like they're
still people who have CD books yeah
listen I don't know who they are they
don't even make calls like that you know
what they say uh country music still
sell CDs so if you go to Walmart ever
they still got CDs there but it's all
country yeah tough I don't know I think
some of them rednecks ain't smart enough
to figure out the streaming I mean it's
probably still money in there yeah my
car does not have a CD player 100 so
it's like what am I supposed to do with
this cities in the 80s
it was mid 90s it was mid 90s for sure
yeah because I had like a nice little CD
book in like 98. good time like tiny
little single page one you know what I'm
saying the CD CD book was crazy but my
pops had all that the worst part was
when someone broke into your car and
jacked your [ __ ] CDs that was like
you lost your life
you ever had your CD stolen no that's
before that [ __ ] man when you had this
like collection of music that you spent
all this thousands of dollars on and
someone got up in your whip and got up
under that seat and took your CD book I
[ __ ] make you want to kill somebody
bro
now we just got the whole CD books in
your phone
100 man